hayatıma 96 yılında başladım
İzmir'de doğdum İzmir'de doğdum İzmir'de
büyüdüm ve hala İzmir'de yaşıyorum
konservatör hayatı çok keyifliydi ve
fakat biraz bilinçsizdi benim için Çünkü
çok küçük yaşta başlıyor Bu eğitim
biliyorsunuz İlkokul 5 sınıf bittikten
sonra orta bir
öğrenimine başladı sene oluyor bizim
için şu anda eğitim sistemi değiştiği
için çok farklı tabii ki 4+4 olduk
Tan sistem değiş
ti 10 yılın bir yolculuk başlıyor çocuk
yaşta
Cansu Hanım ise tekrar geri dönüyorum
inanılmaz bir disiplin açıklayarak
hareketleri öğretiyorlar ve o
hareketleri Siz her gün saatlerce tekrar
ediyorsunuz ve hayatınızın bir parçası
oluyor şu ana kadar kaç defa yaptım
bilmiyorum ne pilli hareketi var ki ömür
boyunca bunu yapıyorum yani ısınma
hareketleri tahmin ederler aramızda dans
etmiş olanlar belki vardır daha önce
bilmiyorum hiç sevgilerinizi aldım ama
yaptığınız hareketlerle gülüyoruz
senelerce bunları yapıyoruz çok büyük
bir sabır gerektiriyor gerçekten
ve sonra ilk okulun temsilleri başlıyor
gösteriler ve hepimiz rol alıyordu
Heyecanla bekliyoruz bakalım
öğretmenlerimizle hangi rolünü gördü ve
sahnede ne yapacağız diye daha Küçük
yaşlarda Aslında çekişme ve kıyafetle
tanışıyoruz
Sonra ailelerinizin bizi izlediği ve
alkışladığı heyecanla tanışıyoruz
seyirciler sizlerle birlikte bu
Koltuklar ne kadar kıymetli ne kadar
kutsal bunu öğreniyoruz Çünkü
ayaklarımız yara oluyor şu pointlerin
ucunda duruyoruz Parmaklarımızı kanıyor
çok acı çekiyoruz sakatlıklar yaşıyoruz
ama ne zaman sahneye çıktığımızda müzik
başladığında Biz Dans etmeye başlıyoruz
o zaman her şeyi unutuyoruz mesela
verdiğimizde tüm seyirci size
alkışlarken İşte o zaman bütün
hastalığın sakatlığın her şeyini
unutuyorsun devamlı tadını çıkar
ıyorsun ilk önce bunun için minnettarım
Atatürk olmasaydı şu an bir kadın ve bir
sanatçı olarak sahnede olamazdım
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
Ondan sonra ki süreç sizi biraz daha
bilinçlendiğimizde liseye ve üniversite
yaşına getirdiğinde artık onu yaralamış
oluyorsunuz Aslında yeni başlıyorsunuz
daha haberiniz yok çok girdim ve ben her
şeyi öğrendim oluyor ihtiyaçlarım bile o
da gelecek ileride sonra gidecek sonra
mezuniyete yaklaş ve bu arada tabi
tecrübeli olması açısından eğitmenlerin
beni yarışmalara gönderiyor Rusya'da ve
Bulgaristan'da 2 tane yarışmaya
katılıyorum uluslararası orada yarı
final ödüllerim oldu İzmir'de düzenlenen
birkaç tane yarışmada yine derecelerin
var bunların hepsini bakabilirsiniz
zaten ulaşabilirsiniz sosyal medya
hesaplarında
Ondan sonra mezuniyet geliyor ve acaba
bu çocuk mezunu olunca ne yapacak
kaygısı başlıyor belki çocukta olduğu
gibi üniversite bitince Acaba ne
yapacağız nerede çalışacağız
hayatımız nasıl idame ettireceğiz Bizim
de şöyle bir sinyalimiz oluyor mezun
olduktan sonra isterseniz Bulunduğunuz
yerdeki işte kurumlarda çalışabilirsiniz
İzmir Devlet Opera Balesi Benim şu anda
çalıştığım durumum
6 ilimizde var Türkiye'de
istanbul-ankara Samsun Mersin Antalya
olmak üzere Keşke daha çok illerimizde
de yayılsa ve daha çok sanatçı yapacak
açabilsek ülkemizde
Ondan sonra olaya girerken bir sınava
tabi tutuluyorsunuz yine konservatuvar
sınavında olduğu gibi ama siz tabi biraz
tanıyor oluyorlar ve Hakkınızda biraz
bilgi sahibi oluyorlar okul
gösterilerine gelip gidiyorlar ve oradan
seçebiliyorlar gelecek vadeden sanatçı
adayı ise bizim kurumumuzda çalıştığımız
almalıyız olur gibi böyle güzel
diyaloglar oluyor ve biz oraya alışmak
için hafta sonları sadece derslere girip
çıkma iznine sahip oluyoruz daha okurken
sonra Opera Hani hayatın başlamış
oluyorlar İzmir'de 2005 yılında mezun
olduktan sonra çalışmaya başlıyorum
sözleşmeli olarak
patronuma alıyorum ve hala şu an
kablosunu olarak dans ediyorlar
17 sezonu mu sanıyorum hala başrol
alıyorum çok güzel bir mesleğim var bunu
gerçekten Gurur duyarak söylüyorum ama
çok zor bir meslek olduğunu da söylemek
zorundayım sizleri bilgi sahibi olması
için
bu göstermek istediğim boyutların ucunda
sıkıştırılmış talaş var
ayaklarımız onun içerisinde şu şekilde
duruyor ve biz üzerine çıktığımızda
bütün vücut ağırlığımızı sadece iki
parmağımız taşıyor O yüzden onların
üzerinde dans etmek bırakın yürümek bile
aslında çok emek ve çok zor acı çekmeyi
gerektiren bir iş çok büyük eserler Dans
ediyoruz kimi zaman 3-4 perde klasik
baleler oluyor kimi zaman model valiler
ve daha farklı ekollerde temsiller
sunuyoruz
en güzel kısmı benim hissettiğim ben
dışarıda burcuyken sahnede başka bir
Burcu olduğunu fark ettim meslek
hayatımda
normal bir kız çocuğuyum evde annesi
babası ve Sevgiyle büyüyen okuluna Giden
gelen bir okulda çok normal
ailenin çocuğu olarak yetişmiştim Fakat
ne zaman hayatıma sanat diyebilirdi Ve
ben bunu tabi bilmiyordum bilinçli
değilim söylediği gibi küçükken ama ne
zaman büyüdüğümde artık bir sanatçı
olduğunu ya da adayı olduğum bu fark
ettiğimde başka bir Burcu olduğumu
hissettim ve sadece kendimden sorumlu
olmadığımı bir gün iyilerde bu mesleği
bıraktığımda benden sonra gelecek olan
resimler için bir şey yapmam gerektiğini
ufak tefek öğrencilerimle böyle küçük
çalışmalarımla onlara dokunmanın ne
kadar güzel olduğunu Benim bildiğim her
şeyi aktarmak için deli olduğumu ve yani
çocukların geleceğimiz olduğunu
çok seviyorum sizi gerçekten Çünkü
Geleceğiniz Bizler bir yerde Daire
teslim etmek zorunda kalacak sizlere o
yüzden böyle pırıl pırıl bakan
Gözleriniz hep öyle baksın istiyorum ve
mutlaka hayatınızın bir kısmında dans
edin ne olduğu önemli değil hayatınızda
sakın Tabii ki hepiniz için geçerli
çünkü hep balede yaşla ilgili sorular
soruluyor bana kaç yaşına kadar dans
edebiliriz erkekler bu işi yapıyor ama
tayt mı giyiyoruz
Şimdi belli normlar var oynamanız
gereken ve gerçekten bazı kıyafetler
baleye uygun olmadığından dolayı erkek
giymek zorunda kalabiliyor
burada artık tepki duyulan bir şey değil
Bir sanatçı olarak değerlendirildiğinde
bir erkek dansçıyla tebrik etmek ve ona
da bence gurur duymasını sağlamayı
gerektirir çünkü bale sadece bir kişi ve
kadın dansı olarak mümkün değil
sergilenmesi o yüzden Partner olarak
ihtiyaç duyuyoruz onlar bize biz onlara
beraber Dans ediyoruz ona patates
ediyoruz erkek ve kadın dansının beraber
sergilediği bölümlere İyi ki varlar
onlarda çok değerli der Onun dışında ne
söyleyebilirim size yurt dışındaki
yarışmalar benim hayatımda çok çok büyük
bir yer kaplıyor
Çünkü ülkemi çok seviyorum biraz bu özel
bir konu benim için biraz milliyetçi bir
insanım yaşanan acılarda travmalarda
bazıları böyle büyük olaylarda sanatçı
olduğumdan kaynaklı olabilir bilmiyorum
Çok etkileniyorum ve bir şey yapmam
gerektiğine inanıyorum
belli dönemlerinde
[Müzik]
3 yıl kadar gönüllü ablalık ya da
annelik olarak bir organizasyonda yer
almıştım oradan iyileşen çocuklarla daha
tedavi gören çocukları birleştirip böyle
bir bana gösterirsiniz yani demek
Onlar da çok güzel bir anım var Onu
söylemek isterim
[Müzik]
tedavisi çok iyi gitmiyordum
[Alkış]
[Müzik]
en güzeli Şu anda ben ciddi olmak
zorunda değilim çünkü konuşmaya devam
etmek zorundayım
inanılmaz bir eğitim aldım O yüzden
bunları öğreniyorsun küçük yaşta o
yüzden devam ediyorum
devam edemiyoruz
Bunlar şunu söylemek istiyorum aslında
benim
[Müzik]
dakika nerede yazıyor bilmiyorum ama
daha vaktim var mı 6 güzel Tamam çok
küçük bir şey de değinmek istiyorum
çünkü bu cam fanus diye bir disiplin
dedik çoğumuz farklı meslekler
seçeceksiniz Tabii ki bale olur olmaz
Bilemiyorum ne çıkar orada ama disiplin
li başarıya ulaşamamak mümkün değil
işimizi çok sevmemiz gerekiyor Ben
sürekli düşüyorum kalkıyorum ve tekrar
ertesi gün prova'ya gidip devam ediyorum
ayağımda kanıyor yara oluyor acıyor
sakatlanıyorum ve tekrar devam ediyorum
Yani büyük bir Azim gerektiren bir
benimki ama her meslek dalı için öyle
olacak Eminim o yüzden size
tavsiyem yılmamanız hiçbir zaman
bırakmamanız işiniz güzelliklerini
bilmektir onu hatırlamanız
sizi tek tek Çünkü ben öyle yaptım yani
yapıyorum seyircimin karşısına sağlıklı
Bir bedende ve sağlıklı Mental güçte
çıkmak benim için çok önemli ama insan
olduğunuz için Tabii ki Makina değiliz
sürekli kurulup böyle o müzik
kutusundaki balerin gibi her gün dans
edemiyoruz Çünkü bazen bir ayda 4 temsil
5 temsil yaptığınız oluyor benim de
insan olarak ateşlenme lüksüm oluyor
arada rahatsızlanma gibisin oluyor Ben
de rahatsızlanıyorum ama ne zaman perde
açılır ve ben
her şeyi unutuyorum Çünkü seyirciyle
buluşmuş oluyorum müzik bir başlıyor ve
rolün içine giriyorum orada kimseye bunu
yaşatmak zorunda değilim çünkü onlar
bilet alıp gelen seyirciler ve Senin
hasta olman çok da önemli değil onlar
için Onlar bu görsel şovu izlemek
istiyorlar Çünkü bu en önemli şey diye
düşünüyorum disiplin
Tıp biliminde Ben hocalarım Rus eğitimi
aldığım için çok şanslı değil Çünkü
gerçekten aranızda mutlaka deneyimleyen
vardır eşimin üniversiteye gidenler ya
da manipurasından Rusların eğitimini
gerçekten çok katı ve hiçbir zaman Ah
canım acıdı mı canım kıyamam sana
tekrar yapacaksın ayağım kanıyorsa bir
daha çıkacaksın bir daha bir daha
şeklinde biraz böyle Sopalı gibi oluyor
ama ben öyle büyüdüm onlar o zaman çok
kızıyordum
[Müzik]
kız ayakkabıları koyayım diyoruz onun
kurdel
Esi önünde Ben gözümden yaşadım ağlamaya
başlamıştım ama küçüktüm orta
birlikteydim ilk yarışmamdı
ve Madem beni böyle bekliyordu Ama
mesela
bana çok kızdı sen nasıl ağlarsın Sen
sahnede dans ediyorsun ağlayamazsın
denendi acısın düşsen de devam etmek
zorundasın ve ben daha orada üzüntümü
içime gömüp acıma böyle hiçbir şey
anlamadan ikinci perdeye tekrar çıkıp
tekrar yarışmaya devam etmek zorunda
kaldı Şimdi başıma böyle yıllar sonra
sahnede talihsiz bir olay geldiğinde
ayağımı burkarsam ya da düşersem bir şey
olursa her zaman bilinçaltında madamın
söylediği var ne olursa olsun kalkıp
devam etmek zorundasın hayatta da
aslında bu geçerli seyirci önünde de
aynı şey geçerli onlara çok teşekkür
ederim İyi ki beni yetiştirmişler çok
şey öğrendim ve şu an meslek hayatımda
da sürekli onları alıyorum İyi ki
onlarla çalışmışım diyorum
o fenomene de
gidince
her değişti
büyüdüm okul hayatında Çok bilinçli
değilim dediğim gibi
orada bir rekabet Tabii ki oluyor Herkes
dans ediyor fakat içlerinden mesela 30
kişi varsa 30 kişi başrol dans edemiyor
10 kişi grupta dans ediyor 4 kişi solist
rollerde oluyor ama bir kişi başrol
O yüzden büyük bir çekişme Tabii ki
oluyor sanatçılar arasında Ama bu
mesleki bir şey olmalı ve Bence kişisel
böyle problemler ya da işte ben onu
sevmiyorum ama beni sevmiyor şöyle dedi
böyle dedi sahnede perde açıldığı anda
bitmeli diye düşünüyorum ki zaten
profesyonel hayatta bu biraz daha
güzelleşiyor büyüdükçe diyebilirim Onun
dışında Size verilen sorumluluk
sırtınıza yüklenen ağırlık çok fazla
dediğim gibi arkamda dans eden 40 kişi
var teknik ekip Işık İçin Bir borcunu
kostümcü orkestra sanatçıları
200 belki 250 kişi Biz siz izlemeye
geldiğimizde bilmiyorum Burada kaç kişi
geldi o paraya temsili dedi ama 250
neredeyse 300 kişi emek veriyor bu işe
sadece görünen sanatçılar olarak Vale ve
orkestra var ama işin arkasında da çok
büyük bir ekip var siz Onların da
sorumluluğunu taşıyor oluyorsunuz Çünkü
perde açıldığında onlar sizi görüyor
geçti arkada kalıyor O yüzden çok büyük
bir sorun yok ben bunu 17 yıldır çok
severek ve gururla taşıyorum Çok da
mutluyum böyle olduğu için her biri çok
değerli hepsinin çok emeği var
onlara da buradan sok Selamlar ve
teşekkürler iyi ki var hepsi
sonra başka bir şeye girmek istiyorum
şimdi Point demiştim ama
bunlar ilk pointlerim neredeyse
Rusya'daki bale yarışmasına katıldığım
zaman kullandığım Rus poin'leri onlardan
biraz bahsetmek istiyorum İçinde
sıkıştırılmış talaş var demiştim
teknoloji Tabii ki ilerliyor ve bizler
yetişemiyoruz şu anki Payı da artık
sıkıştırılmış falan işte yapılmıyor
plastik bir malzeme ile yapılıyor ve biz
bu pointleri giydiğimizde üzerine inip
çıktıkça prova
yapmadı beni
hatırladığım ve tabi her ailenin durumu
buna çok müsait olmayabiliyor O zaman
hiç unutmuyorum 40 dolar mıydı 45 dolar
mı neydi gibi bir durum sonra şimdi
daha ne hale geldi Biz içerisine
gazeteler sokardık işte böyle
annelerimizin elbiselerine
[Müzik]
ayaklarımız acımasın diye onları
koyardım ucuna ama şimdi o
kadar ilerle Makina yıkanabiliyor
İnanabiliyor musunuz
öyle bir döneme geldik bilmiyorum bundan
15-20 olacak artık
bunu da aranızda belki baleye Gönül
veren ya da bilmiyorum Yapmış olan biri
çok istekli olan biri varsa konuşma
bitiminde bir bize hediye etmek isterim
Onun için getirdim yanımda kostümler
imizi bir farklı fark ettiniz mi ama her
zaman Çünkü bilmiyoruz
ütüde bilirsiniz böyle elbise ve bedenin
tam oturan daha çok klasik balelerde
kullanılan bir tercih modern bariyelerde
birçok şekilde sahneye çıkabiliyoruz
kısa taytlar giyiyoruz Sadece düz
mayolar ya da şifon elbiseler birçok
tarzda kostümle Dans ediyoruz saç
ımız var işte her şeyi bize
uygulayarak
ama tamam Evet hemen kapatıyorum Çok
teşekkür ederim dinlediğiniz için iki
şey varsa söylemek istediğim bir tanesi
tüm kız çocuklarımızın bu cam fanus'tan
çıkmalarını diliyorum
ikincisi Atatürk'e gerçekten çok
müteşekkerim Onun sayesinde bir kadınla
bir sanatçı olduğunu tekrar bile
getirmek istiyorum ve biz de çok
teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]